hi I'm Christopher hin and today we're
going to talk about juji nag so what is
juji nag I'm going to give you an
overview of it sometimes called juji
Guma there's lots of different names um
it's the figure 10 position 10 in
Japanese which looks like this um and
that's this position um I know different
people might call this different things
I'm going to tell you why we do it the
way we do it how useful it is because
it's hyper useful although I think again
it's a thing that if you're not doing
regular uh Kishi waza and rondor then
you're you're not going to see it as
much although it comes up a ton of ton
of ton so arm grappling it's super
essential I'm going to call Josh over
here we're going to go to work
[Music]
[Applause]
Josh all right let's talk about some
juji nag so juji is real cool technique
um it's much more useful in armed
grappling um in its like full version
than it is in um more of what I consider
the iido context although it comes up in
iido a fair amount um but you kind of
have to understand what it is and and
basically it's just getting the arms to
cross and then what you're going to do
with the arms from the cross position so
it seems silly you know like I'm going
to grab this guy or something and then
I'm going to
go and I'm going to cross his arms that
seems silly but it happens Happ s really
naturally in lots and lots of ways right
so for example let's say I had a weapon
here right and Josh grabbed me okay uh
grab the other way and it'll just be
easier for the camera okay so he grabs
me here um and I want to clear the
weapon okay now I can clear the weapon
but he's just going to immediately reach
and grab and you're going to kind of
learn this in arm grappling happens a
lot where you make an escape and then
they immediately grab you again right
and this your Escape was no good so I
want to do something so he can't
immediately grab with this hand again
right now I've isolated this hand so
what's he going to do he's going to grab
me with the other hand what did Josh
just do to him himself well he set
himself up for juji nag is what he did
right so that happens constantly uh if
you have an armed grappling practice you
will constantly see one person getting
free and either going to cut the other
person or the other person just
instinctively reaching with that hand
and now we're going to bind one against
the other and that's that's naturally
going to happen over and over and over
in our iido context usually the solution
is going to be simple it's going to be
about that and then bing bang bang bang
bang I'm going to go back to work
because it's a lot more work and time to
deal with this guy stand in up in that
juji position or in any position and I
just want to get rid of him so most of
the time we see them as uh just clearing
techniques right okay so that's going to
happen anytime we're across the body I
grab an isolate a hand I come in to get
him and he stops me that's fine boom uh
and then I'm going to bind up his arms
all right now from the bound up position
what should we be looking for all right
now if we're looking for a taked down um
which could be something you're looking
for there's a few things you want to get
in in line right so one thing you'd like
to do is I want to get the inside of one
of his elbows to touch the inside of the
other elbow now depending on how big his
chest is and how flexible his arms are
that might not even be possible but
that's the angle I'm headed and the more
I head into that angle I'm going to
create a ton of tension in his back
right here right so he's going to feel
like his back's getting ripped apart
because I'm driving this one down and
turning it in like this and I'm driving
this one up and turning it like this so
they're not just being twisted around
each other they're being forced together
so the insides of those elbows are
touching and the more you do that the
more compression he'll get now so what
that will do is it will make him want to
move around because he wants to get the
heck out of there right so I'm like this
and I start doing it and the second he
starts moving that's fine I'm going to
get something in there right and I'm
going to set I'm going to set up some
kind of position all right now how do I
get the taked down well I can get it in
tons of ways right now I have to work
with these cameras but so no you're fine
uh I could get it here by doing a back
leg
sweep I could do it in an intense way
like a koshin right so I can set them up
with a koshin that way um if he he wants
to take High Falls I can just drive into
him like this and I say wants to take
High Falls meaning that I could just
torque his arm so hard that he'll let
himself come over um because he's just
getting torqued so much and he doesn't
like it but that's the a number of ways
right I can do it front leg sweeps right
so I can come in here I can sweep his
legs all kinds of ways I can get this
guy down from there any classic throw
you would see from a Jiu-Jitsu school is
available to you in this jujin nag
position even if you look in some old
text there's C n is done like this right
so anytime I got those arms bound up
it's just going to be slightly easier to
throw them with a classic take down and
throw in iido usually you're seeing it
where I turn and he turns his body this
way and then boom he just comes down
okay now from this
perspective what how am I going to pin
this guy okay now there's tons of pins
that are done in classic iido I use my
own pin um that I think works really
good it's the only face up pin I have in
my system which is to once he's juji
here drive this Shin across that arm
right and it will trap it really well
get that arm out of there real hard to
right because this arm's trapping him on
top and I have it secure and this leg my
whole leg and all my body's driving into
him then this hand cap sorry Josh I'll
take a little pressure off I take this
hand off and I cap the elbow okay now
this is a really decent position to hold
him now as he's squirming around I do
basically knee ride which you would do
like so if you did Brazilian jiu-jitsu a
knee rides just I put I rest all my
weight on top of him this way and then
as he moves around I stay with him you
do exactly the same thing except you got
those arms C while you're doing it
what's great about this is even if he
had a knife say in this hand and he
stabs me yeah okay maybe he had a knife
in this hand and he stabs me okay really
really hard to use those weapons it also
means it's hard for him to get a weapon
so if I'm doing some kind of control and
I'm scared this guy's got a weapon
somewhere I don't know about that juji
pin will work really well for you now
all of that's really in the context of
armed grappling right so for an iot
Contex most of the time
I use juji just as hoki right so let's
say Josh had me here right so he'd grab
me and I come over to pop him boom just
driving one arm into the other and
that's juji you can see it right there
so juji just figure 10 like this that's
how I use it most the time is just to
escape so I'm using it just to pop free
so I don't have an obsession with using
it to control him I just have an
obsession with getting free and it will
happen all the time where he's doing one
thing with one hand and he'll reach
across his body so anytime you can get
them to do this or they choose to do
this you can get juji in that
automatically and you should be using it
because it'll come up a lot and it
really is kind of confusing to their
brain and out of that you'll end up
getting other things as well so it's a
good setup for other things so that's an
overview of juji Nag what I think it's
useful for how it comes up how I do the
pin um that's it I'm Christopher Hines
Joshua T my salon mcdel hanging out over
there all right thanks a lot for
watching
oh